[Musique]
nous allons vous conter l'histoire les
aventures des aventures
nous allons vous conter l'histoire des
aventures de renard
c'est encore une fois il va se faire
visitant hier
[Musique]
et pardonne à son compère
la mission de brens ayant échoué cet
hiver le chat qui est chargé à son tour
par le roi de ramener renard à la cour
[Musique]
renard êtes vous là répondez-moi
bienvenue thibert ne m'en voulez pas
renhar pour la mission dont je suis
chargé je viens de la part du roi chaque
gens à la cour se plaint de vous le roi
menace seul votre cousin grimbert le
blaireau et votre défenseur les menaces
ne tue pas
j'irai à la cour et j'y verrais bien
qu'ils portent plainte contre moi ce
sera sage renard et je vous le conseille
en ami je me suis pressé dans ma mission
je m'aperçois que je meurs de faim
[Musique]
n'auriez-vous pas quelque chose à manger
hélas ce tout ce que je pourrai vous
trouvez ce serait quelques rats ou
souris comment des sourires mais vous
savez que je ne me nourrir ait pas
d'autres saut vous n'avez qu'à me suivre
[Musique]
nous arrivons chez le prêtre son grenier
est bien fourni en froment et en avoine
les souris s'en donnent à coeur joie
[Musique]
voici le trou par où il faut entrer
passé et régalez vous
[Musique]
l'abonné renard et prix venait
on
[Musique]